happy death day is basically Groundhog
Day meets Halloween but if it were ever
to get a third installment it could end
up being so much more but will happy
death day 3 ever actually be produced
stick around to learn the freaky truth
the biggest obstacle in the way of happy
death day 3 being made is the box office
woes that its predecessors dealt with
sure happy death day to you still
received plenty of positive critical and
audience Acclaim and turned a profit
like the original but it wasn't nearly
as much of a success on a 9 million
dollar budget the film grossed around 64
million dollars worldwide just about
half of the original's 125 million
dollar haul while that's still an
impressive feat it's not even close to
the accomplishments of the original and
even director Christopher Landon knows
it during an interview with Slash film
Landon said it's very hard to motivate
them to make a third movie when the last
one just didn't perform congrats
oh and by the way you're gonna die
again
and again and again unfortunately for
fans the profitability of a movie is the
biggest factor in pushing Studios to
Green Light further installments in a
franchise happy death day to you simply
couldn't reach the marks it needed to
make the dream of another sequel a
reality
ever since the release of happy death
day to you and its disappointment at the
box office there's been a lot of chatter
from Christopher Landon in blumhouse
Head Jason Blum about the future of the
happy death day franchise Landon has
been talking about doing happy death day
3 for quite some time and he's even
mentioned plans to change the genre up a
bit more with a potential third film the
comments from Blum though were much more
interesting as he told inverse that
discussions were still happening on the
film Blum elaborated the reason it's
still alive is because I'm very
passionate about it it's very rare that
you make a second sequel after a movie
that didn't perform very well but I want
to do it because I thought the second
movie was spectacular unfortunately
according to Landon it seems like those
discussions have stalled when talking
with Slash film Landon was pessimistic
stating there was a tiny moment where I
really felt like I had Universal's
attention but they forgot about me it
seems like the talks around happy death
day 3 have halted and chances of a third
installment look slim for now
based on the ending of happy death day
to you and Christopher Landon's
follow-up plans there's plenty to
speculate on when it comes to what a
third film could explore happy death day
to you ended with a post-credits scene
that saw tree and her friends picking up
trash as community service for the
destruction they caused that is until
DARPA agents swarm them and take them to
their facility where they say that
they're looking to experiment more on
the reactor and they need their help
finding a test subject
wait you
you want to trap somebody in a timeline
that's messed up
unless they deserve it that's why the
final scene depicts Danielle as she
wakes up from a Time Loop of her own
it's unknown whether This was meant to
be more of a gag or an actual idea for
the sequel but a stronger focus on
Danielle is certainly One Direction the
series could go in Landon has talked in
more detail about his potential happy
death day 3 plans to the press and
they're not what you might be expecting
in a discussion with the rap about the
rumored third film Landon mentioned that
he wanted a bigger budget that would fit
his vision he told the outlets the third
movie was going to be an epic
apocalyptic adventure with still
elements of horror but yeah we were
going to change gears again and it was
going to be bigger
While most of the cast of the first two
films haven't said much about possibly
returning for a third happy death day
there are at least some signs that main
star Jessica Roth is interested in
returning when talking with Cinema Blend
about working with Roth Landon had
nothing but positive things to say
joking she's my work wife she's one of
my best friends now we talk all the time
still we're working on something else
together right now I would love to make
movies and create stuff with her for the
rest of my life she's amazing it's clear
that Landon would love to reunite with
Roth for literally any project including
happy death day 3 and Roth has expressed
the same interest Roth gave her own take
on the future of the franchise telling
collider we only want the movie to
happen if it's going to happen in the
right way to finish out tree's story to
really give support to the two
incredible films that we made before and
to honor our fan base
guys I have literally been killing
myself to memorize this for you failure
is not an option
another big reason that happy death day
3 may never happen is that there have
been some frustrations expressed by
Christopher Landon over how Universal
handled his last collaboration with them
freaky was one of the many victims of
the covet pandemic and was used by
Universal for their new same-day
streaming and theatrical release
strategy this caused the film to have a
very poor box office performance much to
Landon's frustration when Universal
tried to do the same release strategy
with Halloween kills Lenin took to
Twitter to advocate for Studios to stop
trying this risky strategy he tweeted
Studios stop gambling with filmmakers
and their movies to try and prop up your
fledgling streaming services this
happened to me on freaky and it
destroyed us even a year later Landon
was still harboring some frustrations
with how Universal treated freaky so
there could definitely be some
unresolved tensions between the two
parties that's keeping happy death day 3
from being made perhaps it's also why
Landon chose not to make his following
films with the studio
while it's nice to imagine that
Christopher Landon can simply jump right
into making happy death day 3 he's very
busy with some other exciting projects
Landon's latest film we have a ghost was
released on Netflix in 2023 delivering
some fun ghost Antics that the whole
family can enjoy after that Landon is
tasked with a huge Endeavor to write and
direct a remake of arachnophobia it was
reported in 2022 that Landon would be
joining the remake of the 1990 horror
comedy classic and there have been some
signs that production on the film is set
to start soon when speaking with
discussing film about the status of his
Arachnophobia remake Landon teased were
getting super close the script's done
I've been working on that for a while
now so now it's just really about
getting it together with this in mind it
might be a little while until Landon has
the time to work on Happy death day 3.
at one point happy death day was a big
original franchise for blumhouse thanks
to its financial success and why to
claim within the horror Community
fitting in nicely alongside their other
franchises like Sinister and Insidious
now though blumhouse has started to
evolve and it may be that they have
already outgrown the need for another
happy death day blumhouse has some new
original horror tentpoles forming like
the Wily successful Megan and the black
phone both of which have sequels coming
in the near future they're starting to
take on bigger already established
franchises with films like their
upcoming Take On The Exorcist the
long-awaited adaptation of the video
game Five Nights at Freddy's and Todd
McFarlane's spawn reboots while
blumhouse is not against giving their
older franchises new entries like
Insidious the red door and Paranormal
Activity next of kin it's becoming
increasingly hard to believe that they
do the same for happy death day the
disappointing box office performance of
happy death day to use seems to be a
real sticking point for Universal
Executives so if blumhouse can find more
financially successful Avenues with new
films it's doubtful that they'll feel
the need to return
on paper there are plenty of reasons why
Universal in blem house wouldn't want to
do a third happy death day film the poor
box office performance of the sequel and
strong genre competition would make it a
risky Venture still a third installment
could still be a worthwhile wave for the
studio to pay their respects to one of
their less fleshed out franchises along
with the cast and crew that brought it
together
it's clear that Landon Jessica Roth and
likely the rest of the cast are ready to
send this series out on an ambitiously
high note that'll surely reignite
interest from more than just the core
fan base as a character tree has
definitely earned herself a Trilogy of
her own and fans would be thrilled to
see her return to the big screen one
last time plus there's options outside a
theatrical release that Landon said he's
open to in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Landon mentioned that
he'd even be willing to make happy death
day 3 for peacock if it meant that it
could see the light of day saying we
could do it for peacock it doesn't have
to be theatrical I prefer it but it
doesn't have to be I know I've been a
bad roommate but isn't this a bit much
what the hell after screwing up the
theatrical release of freaky a chance on
Happy death day 3 seems like the least
Universal in blumhouse could do
if the dreams of happy death day 3 being
made can't come true then Universal and
blumhouse could try to make the rumors
of a happy death day and freaky
crossover a reality for quite some time
there have been rumors swirling about a
crossover film for Christopher Landon's
two most prominent horror films and
Landon has actually addressed the
possibility of the film's existence
during his interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Landon joked look Jason Blum is
the Puppet Master he's pulling all the
strengths so if anybody knows it's him I
know that Jessica Catherine Newton and I
would love to get together and make
something absolutely ridiculous so it's
possible but we really haven't had an
actual creative conversation about doing
something like that while actual plans
haven't been made yet the idea of a
crossover film is out there and it
definitely has potential more
importantly if it did come out it would
be the continuation of happy death day
that fans of the film deserve
[Music]